[Musique]
et moi ont pu savoir des divergences sur
une
des choses peuvent exister mais c'est
pour ça qu'il fait que je quitte sa
fille avait pas de contrairement à ce
que certains ont dit de différence
d'orientation avec nous autres mais de
façon personnelle et de choisir que
pourraient d'habitants de passer à autre
chose je respecte ça
PDG Diderot Québec sur sa décision de
quitter la direction de la société des
tailles la réaction de François Legault
et surtout l'assurance que cela n'a rien
à voir directement avec la relation où
les tensions entre Sophie brocheux et le
gouvernement logo comment interpréter
cette annonce qui est quand même été
surprenante cette semaine c'est
là-dessus qu'on lance la discussion avec
nos panélistes cette semaine elle est
cassanguée est animateur de midi info et
s'y première et chroniqueur autoroute
star et au magazine L'actualité et
Michel Surget est analyste politique à
La Presse et Radio-Canada bonne année à
vous trois
merci bonne année Michel qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé madame contrat de Madame
Brochu est encore valide pour quelques
années le salaire est intéressant les
conditions de travail sont pas mauvaises
pourquoi auraient-elles décider au
lendemain de la période des fêtes qu'il
était temps d'aller voir ailleurs
parce que peut avoir les faits il y a eu
une première réunion de sa comité
ministérielle
auquel elle était conviée sur
du Québec et de toute évidence c'est le
vu que le courant de passerait pas on
peut dire après ça non non
et tout à la fin il y a un seul
actionnaire de sa compagnie c'est le
gouvernement alors c'est l'actionnaire
qui va décider et Madame brochure a
décidé que ce combat-là était perdu
d'avance bien simplement bon elle va
dire le contraire on est au Québec et
petit villavenir dure longtemps
mais de toute évidence elle était pas
sur la même longueur d'onde que le
gouvernement puis qu'on a vu monsieur
Legault et Monsieur fetieren cette
semaine tombé exactement dans ce que
Madame brochez vous voulez pas faire on
a des kilowatts qui sont prêtes qu'on va
lui donner à tous ceux qui veulent
développer le Québec c'est exactement ce
que dit changement cap quand même
Chantal par rapport à l'attitude qu'elle
avait adopté il y a quelques mois pas à
peine où elle disait il est pas question
c'était inscrit en faux essentiellement
contre l'attitude du gouvernement là il
a vraiment juste dit non non ça va aller
qu'est-ce que vous lisez là-dedans
à peu près la même chose que Michel j'ai
l'impression que c'est donner le temps
de voir venir de voir ce comité là
clairement la masse critique autour de
cette table là était assez évidente et
je ne crois pas qu'elle parte en pleine
crise qui permet à tout le monde d'être
en train de dire la vérité mais je crois
que si elle avait vu des lendemains qui
chantent dans sa boule de cristal après
cette réunion là probablement qu'elle
sera encore là et et qu'à la fin en
regardant la boule de cristal c'est dit
les lendemains qui chantent non
seulement il y en aura pas non seulement
il va y avoir de plus en plus de fausses
notes et de difficultés à accorder les
violons entre une partie et l'autre mais
ça risque de mener à un départ en pleine
crise ce que je crois personne voulait
et qui était dans l'intérêt de personne
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour la CAQ
avec
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est pas
une bonne nouvelle même si sophie Brochu
et sincère convaincante le gouvernement
dit également il y a pas de conflit
c'est pas pour ces raisons là qu'elle
quitte reste que elle était une PDG à la
grande notoriété gros capital de
sympathie les gens l'apprécient même les
gens qui ne suivent pas de près
l'économie la politique les questions
environnementales savent qu'ils sophie
Brochu savent que c'était une
gestionnaire de talents on avait
travaillé des années littéralement des
années pour l'attirer Hydro-Québec elle
avait dit non plusieurs fois finalement
en pleine pandémie elle avait accepté et
on est en état on en était très fier sur
le goût d'avoir réussi à attirer ce
fibrochu quel quitte deux ans avant la
fin de son mandat c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle il faudra nommer un ou une
nouvelle PDG qui a quand même des gros
souliers à chausser qui devra être un
assez bon communicateur on n'est plus à
l'air seulement des gestionnaires pour
expliquer pourquoi Hydro-Québec prend
certaines décisions avec la transition
énergétique ce sera pas simple de
trouver quelqu'un à la fois au conseil
d'administration faut pas l'oublier la
PDG du conseil d'administration la scène
côté quitte
donc présidence du conseil
d'administration président aux
Hydro-Québec pour la carte ça va être
deux nominations très importantes mais
ça ne pouvait pas être une bonne semaine
pour eux ça c'était assez clair ok
qui est capable de bonne sensibilité
très particulière au dossier autochtone
des choses que Madame Brochu avec et
ceux d'entre nous qui sont assez vieux
pour avoir été là à l'époque de Grande
Baleine on s'en souvient d'Hydro-Québec
avec ces grosses ces gros souliers qui
c'est qui a mis les pieds du Québec dans
les plats et qui a fini par voir le
projet avorter alors l'idée qu'on va
revenir à la mentalité le développement
c'est bon et ça c'est beau de de là
parce que l'intérieur supérieur du
Québec le commande sérieusement et c'est
un peu la mentalité qu'on a vu
dans certaines des déclarations de
Monsieur Facebook
sérieusement ça peut pas se racheter
juste en s'achetant un complet vert et
ça fonctionne pas prédiction d'échec
annoncés quelqu'un qui a pas ce doigté
là va voir les projets qui va où elle va
tenter de mener à bien pour réaliser les
objectifs plus ou moins bien planifié du
gouvernement
comme une grande baleine se casser la
figure en clair Michel rapidement votre
point de vue là
faut pas oublier que Jacques perizot
avait arrêté alors que c'était bien
avancé c'est bien plus loin que ce qui
peut être un projet actuellement
au Québec ou dans la tête des gens à
Québec alors
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de facteurs sur
ça les autochtones américains
l'environnement n'est un autre et ça
c'est les deux angles morts du
gouvernement logo alors il faut pas se
surprendre que c'est là que de là que le
problème vient mais il reste que il faut
que le gouvernement surveille ses
règlements parce que c'est vraiment un
problème nomination qui va être qui va
devoir être fait de façon
délicate bon un autre dossier dont on a
parlé un peu à Québec mais beaucoup
Ottawa cette semaine c'est l'utilisation
de consultant la ferme Kenzie qui depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des libéraux et a
obtenu plus de 60 millions de dollars en
contrat c'est pas mal plus que sous le
gouvernement précédent cette semaine
n'est parti d'opposition sont entendues
pour amener d'affaires devant un comité
de réactions puis on lance la discussion
là ils vont devoir rendre des comptes je
ne suis pas convaincu que les gens
soient heureux de savoir qui payent deux
fois pour des services et qu'à la fin de
la journée ceux qui partent avec
l'argent c'est ceux qui vont faire des
profits tout le bilan du travail tout
l'argent impliqué tous les conversations
tous les textos les les
courriels et tout ça sera obligé d'être
public
avec c'est pas une habituel qu'un
gouvernement fasse appel à des au
service de consultants mais c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup cette semaine
qu'est-ce que vous comprenez de ça
moderne on veut pas prendre de décision
trop radicale trop importante sans aller
vers des films de consultants qui vont
mettre leur gros étables sur notre
réforme pour pas se faire critiquer je
ne le sais pas mais il y a des fois
l'impression qu'on en abuse un peu de
ces cabinets conseils c'est souvent bien
aller chercher de l'accès extérieur des
idées qui se fait ailleurs dans le monde
quand les rendus des chiffres comme ça
il y a matière à se poser des questions
qu'est-ce qui fait mal Chantal est-ce
que c'est les liens que le gouvernement
Trudeau entretient avec la firme
monsieur Burton comme le disait Alex ou
c'est la quantité contre
on s'entend le 60 millions c'est une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan des dépenses
publiques du gouvernement fédéral
quelque chose que vous verriez même pas
si vous passez à travers les états
financiers du gouvernement tellement
c'est minuscules à l'ensemble des
dépenses la vraie question c'est est-ce
que de plus en plus on ne recourt à des
firmes conseils et moi je vois pas un
grand et sombre complet jusqu'à preuve
du contrat qui fait que le bureau du
premier ministre envoie au ministère de
l'Immigration un message pour dire ce
sont nos trames donner l'ordre des
contrats
mais Kenza en passant pas besoin de ça
c'est aussi une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan de ses revenus ça aussi ça
compte mais
est-ce que de plus en plus la fonction
publique fédérale et de moins en moins à
la hauteur de ces missions et si oui
est-ce que ça veut dire que le talent
qui pourrait être à la hauteur de ces
missions là va gravité vers les films de
consultant c'est un petit peu le débat
entre les cliniques privées en santé et
les cliniques publiques si c'est plus
payant puis ça fonctionne plus
facilement dans le privé on va appauvrir
le public qui va être de moins en moins
à la hauteur cela dit dans ce cas-ci je
pense que ce serait intéressant d'avoir
une commission parlementaire sur l'état
du ministère fédéral de l'immigration
qui me semble à sa façon
il se passe quelque chose qui va pas
dans ce ministère là et ça se peut que
le recours à Mackenzie à cette hauteur
là soit plus un symptôme d'une grave
maladie que ça cause Michel là-dessus
le problème de ces maisons consultant
c'est aussi un problème de transparence
gouvernementale parce qu'après ça
fonctionne sans les lois d'accès
d'information sans les barrières qui
permettent de circonscrire à un moment
donné un certain nombre de choses qui
demandent public avec des une politique
de transparence certains documents et
après ça peut toujours dire les autres
d'ailleurs nous on fait juste donner des
conseils on décide de rien c'est de ne
pas nous voir nous nous on fait juste
décider elle décida alors ça c'est ces
troubles-là un peu moi non plus je vois
pas de ma chambre complot
prononcé tout le monde en moi mais le
problème est vraiment le recours de plus
en plus systématique assez firmes là au
détriment de la fonction publique
l'effet que ça peut avoir sur la
fonction publique l'affaire que ça peut
avoir sur la transparence parce que là
on n'est pas encore devant un comité
parlementaire mais ça va être on va
ressasser tout ça je vais vous entendre
et je commence avec vous Chantal sur la
sortie de Monsieur Ford cette semaine en
Ontario qui tenait un coup est ouvert à
des conditions pour du financement pour
davantage de financement en matière de
santé on a l'impression que le front
commun des provinces s'effrite un peu
quand vous
ou bien le front commun des provinces se
déplacent ce qui est une proposition
quand même un peu différente
je suis gros je suis fort je suis
l'Ontario et il y arrive avec ce
discours là un peu dans la même veine
que le ton de François Legault avant
Noël à la sortie de sa rencontre avec
Justin Trudeau c'est François Legault
premier qui a dit je suis plus optimiste
en sortant que je détais à enfants et je
comprends que le premier ministre veut
pas convoquer les provinces s'il y a pas
une chance raisonnable de terminer avec
un succès alors quand on regarde les
deux déclarations celle de François
Legault celle de dogford et on n'a pas
entendu d'autres premiers ministres
depuis ce temps-là dire non non non
c'est pas ça du tout et dogford est un
largeur c'est pas ce qui s'est passé en
même temps Justin Trudeau qui a beaucoup
modéré son langage on parle plus de
normes nationales cette semaine dans
dans ce qu'on les extraits qu'on a passé
monsieur Trudeau parlait de Para
il prononce même plus le mot confiance
c'est que d'un côté comme de l'autre on
a mis
nécessairement de l'eau dans son vin
autant que dans son discours parce que
il s'était tous les deux mené ensemble
dans une impasse qui profitait à
personne les gens qui regardent ça
disait c'est quoi ça fait là se dialogue
de sourd par médias interposés et là il
y a un repositionnement selon moi des
deux côtés même que peut-être que celui
de Monsieur Trudeau et plus significatif
que celui de Monsieur Ford ou de
Monsieur Lebeau Michel là-dessus
je pense surtout qu'on assiste au début
de la mise en application de l'une des
règles de notre ami et chroniqueurs Paul
well vous savez ça règle qui dit en
politique canadienne lorsque un enjeu le
dénouement tant naturellement vers la
solution la plus plate mais ça risque
d'être ça va
finir par s'entendre on est en politique
canadienne tout le monde va mettre un
petit peu d'eau dans son discours puis
finalement on va avoir une entente à
quelle hauteur il reste encore les
montagnes
un bras de fer quand même au-delà des
normes nationales et tous les on
s'entend pas sur longtemps mais
n'empêche qu'on a vu l'accélération
cette semaine je pense d'une entente
est-ce que ça est-ce qu'elle va survenir
avant le budget ça dépend de la date du
budget mais je pense que d'ici
raisonnablement là quelques semaines
deux trois mois on devrait avoir une
règle de Power ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas entendu je l'aime cette
règle-là le dénouement est souvent le
plus plateforme
en fait on verra où est-ce qu'on en est
c'est tout le temps qu'on a
malheureusement Alexandra Michel merci
infiniment